going into this cartoon Charlie hillbow
and pretty much summarizing it was like
we don't need bombs anymore right what
are your thoughts you know and this goes
back to what you're saying we're people
who don't respect disrespect other
people's religions we're not looking to
you know provoke but it seems like you
know people in the mainstream meeting
others don't come out to condemn these
things but then when Muslims will step
out some lunatic does something but you
know you had how many people now with
this tragic event with the uh her the
earthquake did you hear about this uh
it's about this drawing with the oh did
you hear about it yeah
um at a time where there's more than 20
000 people that have lost our lives
um 100
000 plus that have been affected by this
tragedy instead of showing sympathy to
the victims instead of showing Humanity
these
you know Charlie hebdo and and people in
France and other places have been making
caricatures and cartoons mocking them
and what's interesting is this is done
under the guise of free speech talking
about well we believe that you can mock
anything you we believe in having
freedom of speech but I challenge them
the same cartoonists the same magazine
to go make a cartoon than about the the
Holocaust
in Austria till today I was there myself
it is illegal for you to even question
whether the Holocaust happened or not
and again we as Muslims we're not saying
that this is our stance we're just
saying that if you are going to talk
about freedom of speech then why is hate
speech a thing why can you be arrested
for hate speech and how is this not hate
speech when you curse the prophet who is
more beloved to us than our own parents
right this is a this is a disgusting
show of trying to get attention of the
misery of others that at a time where
more than 20 000 have lost their lives
when we're still digging the dead and
alive out of the the the rubble of an
earthquake you're mocking them you're
saying we don't need bombs because we
just hope that the people of Syria and
turkey are dead one way or the other how
disgusting is that and where are the
politicians standing up where are the
where are the where is the human right
appeal and where are the Amnesty
International and where is all these
organizations that talk where's that
little girl from Sweden that you know
was all up in arms about things where's
their disgust silence it seems like
nobody's saying anything this is the the
hypocrisy if you if you use an
anti-semitic term and and we condemn
that we don't we don't condone
anti-Semitism if somebody uses a racist
term against
African-Americans we condemn that
we in America we realize that's hate
speech you can be arrested you can be
and if you use threatening language you
can be put in jail for it for words
but when people use that against Muslims
then there's nothing
you know there's laws in many countries
against burning Flags you can be
arrested and put in jail for burning the
flag of a country but when somebody's
burning something more dear to us than a
flag the Quran people say well that's
freedom of speech it's a double standard
it's not fair you know when you talk
when you even question the policies of a
particular country called Israel you'll
be called the anti-semite even though
you're just questioning the politics of
a country
right Arabs are Semitic people you know
so I don't know how you can call them
anti-semites right but when you when you
attack a people when you wish for their
destruction when you burn their holy
scriptures when you mock their Prophet
when you call for their death like these
people from Child you have to have done
whether through bombs or natural
disasters silence
why why that's the big question why Shay
what do you have to say about that you
know I actually read a report that the
most passive reaction to a disaster
Collective disasters in the world
from the United Nations from all these
other organizations imagine if this
earthquake happened in France
how
that is 20 000 20 000 dead and they are
still digging yeah and nobody is moving
nobody is moving to help them they're
dragging their feet they are dragging
their feet and they are you know they're
much passive
because it's the lives of Muslims is is
is is achieved for them you know and and
but you know at the end of the day
look at this Eddie
it is
what they have is the what is hamiya is
is the uh the the Zeal of jehilia
now Charlie that's a Zeal of ignorance
of ignorance it's a misguided Zealot
approach of the ignorant you know you
know this verse was revealed when the
Muslims
and their way to perform ombra and the
disbelievers stopped them
and they were wearing the Haram and they
refused for them to enter Makkah
and
who was not a Muslim at the time
he actually came in order to incite
Muslims so that they would
do some attacks so they would kill them
but
the prophet and Allah commanded them to
stay still so even with this
you know nasty and humane
you know Behavior by this Charlie thing
you know we're still not gonna react to
them because
you know we're gonna fear Allah in them
and we're going to make Dua for them
that Allah guides them and we're going
to invite them to Islam and we're going
to make Dua for our deceased you know
because we hope that these brothers and
sisters who lost their lives in turkey
and Syria
are Martyrs that they take on the
rulings of Martyrs
because the prophet salallahu alaihi
added four categories
to dying in the cause of Allah in the
battlefield someone who is crushed had
someone who drowns someone who's plagued
someone who is
from a stomach disease so certainly
there are those who were crushed the the
the walls falling on them and those who
drown somehow we hope that they will die
at shaheeds you know that's what we
believe you know we we don't make
mockery of that you know we don't do
that death is is one of because
everybody is going to face it but what
really matters is is how uh you know how
you die so uh may Allah have mercy on
these brothers you know may you know
it's it's very sad you know especially
guide a lot of the people in the west
that
would mock the death of anybody we as
Muslims don't Mark the deaths of people
many times they take a video of somebody
celebrating a wedding and they're like
all these guys are celebrating something
else and they try to make these tricks
but as Muslims no we feel sorrow yeah
didn't even uh the last final mission
was sent to mankind Muhammad peace and
blessing be upon him he was seeing a
procession of funeral procession and he
stood up it was actually a Jewish man
yeah and then he was asked why he says
isn't this a soul
so what kind of depraved individuals you
would think now there should be a call
by the mainstream either by politicians
against this they need Hill they need
help back again but their their
newspaper Afters the backlash you know
from politicians from the world stage
they should be run out of business
actually at the end that nobody should
be buying their newspapers for anybody
to to go ahead and with what do you
think I mean this is the whole point
that good people yeah
we're not we're not going to wait for
politicians we're not going to wait for
the the moles who run the media
campaigns and have the you know these
tyrants they kind of take over
Industries like the media and then
running these people are only out there
to make money
but good average Americans Europeans and
people around the world good humans
whether Muslim or not should stand up
against this in a peaceful manner like
the Sheikh said we're not going to react
to this in in a violent manner we're
going to react to this with peaceful
response but people should react with
their Wallet not financially support or
buy such organizations that call for the
mockery of innocent death people should
see the hypocrisy non-muslims should
look at this just like we see the war in
Ukraine has exposed the hypocrisy of the
West about refugees
you know the war in Syria which the U.S
and Russia and other interest people
were involved in instigating and and and
and taking to a different level one side
arming one and the other that's a good
point when those Syrian children
refugees women elderly were coming to
the borders of countries like Poland
there were signs saying we don't want
you here we don't care if you're
children we don't care if you're women
we don't care if you just came from war
we don't want you here
and the same countries When The War
happened Ukraine and we feel for the
people of Ukraine we feel for the for
the crisis there we feel for the dead we
we we respect the fact that that's human
life
but when those people from Ukraine came
those same countries were opening their
borders why
why is a Ukrainian child any different
than a Syrian child why is a life of a
Turkish any different from a life of a
French
people who talk about human lives and
talk about Humanity should ask
themselves that question and raise that
question with their politicians and
raise that question with these
newspapers even if you're not Muslim you
should stand up for what is right
and we would like to invite all of you
to yourself learn about Islam
this is the response that we want from
the non-muslim community to these types
of newspapers or Quran burnings is don't
listen to them yourself go like the
beautiful Hadith that Sheikh mentioned
about
yourself you are intelligent enough to
know right from wrong Allah has given
you Allah has given you this brain this
intelligence to know right from wrong
yourself learn about The Message of
Islam how beautiful is the message of
Islam the message of one creator that
cure that loves you that wants good for
you that wants guidance for you that
doesn't kill his own son for salvation
that can forgive you just from you
asking forgiveness
that can guide you from you asking for
guidance that creator that doesn't put
upon you any burden more than you can
handle that creator that that wants you
to have that Everlasting Bliss in a
Jannah in Paradise
so read the message learn about Islam
from Muslims and then you can evaluate
right from wrong
you can know this I'll tell you one
thing
we have a brother in San Diego his name
is Hamza
and he became Muslim because of Fox News
you know this is Brother you know his
brother we saw him in the Masjid one
time started talking to him
and subhanallah he didn't know any
Muslims didn't know about Islam
and he's watching Fox News and he saw a
very negative uh not balanced portrayal
of Muslims
but him not realizing what this is about
he said man who are these people this is
barbaric this is great there's some
gangsters like this is crazy
and he started to learn he went himself
but he was intelligent enough that he
didn't just blindly follow what he saw
he went and he got a Quran he got books
about Islam for the life he learned and
he became a Muslim himself
alhamdulillah is married to a Muslim
sister they have kids now we know him so
all of these these negative portrayals
these these unbalanced this this
hypocritical freedom of speech being
misused to hide hate speech and to stop
the message all of this all we ask is
for the people to use your own
intelligence and go and learn about
Islam and we hope from Allah that Allah
guides Us and Them and gives us is
takama steadfastness on the religion
just a couple more questions that you
made a good really good point you can
imagine if something horrificed like
this you had this earthquake happening
like just a place you mentioned Ukraine
and imagine now the outlash somebody's
mocking this right I mean would you
consider hate speech you know would be
considered you mean you had yeah you had
the example you had uh you had the
example of them trying to we we know we
don't have any original Torah but what's
today of the Torah they tried to go
ahead someone was just gonna play like
they're going to uh but not actually
burn it and they came down and said no
that's not gonna you heard about this
right yeah but they're allowing the
crown to be burned it's still there's
this blatant hypocrisies to have you got
you have uh fathers who are bringing
their children you know out of this
Rubble babies coming out child is stuck
under all this Rubble you know what I
mean their whole life is just right in
front of them just to mock 20 000 plus a
hundred thousand people affected women
that are that are holding their little
infant children that have been crushed
would you say this is this is a
production I don't think any person who
be it he someone who's truly let's say a
Christian or anybody of a god con
someone who has who believes in God this
is like void of God this is like this is
the result of no believer in any
morality in any you have to be depraved
deprived of any morality like the Sheikh
said they're they're sick they have a
sickness these are people who like uh
probably uh indulgent bestiality I mean
also I mean this is whether you can't I
don't know you just have to be sick
minded to go ahead and mock 20 000
people dying does it and I can't write
your mind where is it at if you look at
where's your heart sickness of the
hearts the sickness of the heart it
blinds the eyes yep it deafens the ears
it covers the intellect because the
sickness it begins in the heart and it
goes back don't the cure for it is the
Quran yeah if you see people for example
Jeffrey Dahmer's would eating children
and things and you look at serial
killers and mass murderers and you think
how could they do this
and then you realize that it's because
their heart was diseased when you don't
have a morality that is set through
Divine laws then everybody defines their
own morality
you know where are the lines then we as
Muslims we have the Quran we have the
guidance from the words of Allah and we
have the Sunnah we have what the prophet
peace and blessings be upon Him taught
us we know that even in times of War we
have constraints we cannot just go in as
they did in Guantanamo or in Abu garib
and other places where they just you
know use dogs for torturing and biting
and then Mass gang rapes we cannot do
any of this because we as Muslims know
that there are rules and regulations
even for war and that's why historically
people talk about terrorism and things
let's look at history can I uh give the
narration uh which is so beautiful while
the Sheikh is talking just don't lose
your point oh sorry yeah just finished
finish here yeah if you look at the
Spanish Inquisition and you look at the
difference between that and when
salahuddin ayubi salad as they
mispronounce
took uh Palestine you know when Saladin
according to Western historians
non-muslim historians and they've made
movies about this now when he took the
holy city he allowed there to be
churches he allowed there to be
synagogues he allowed people to practice
their religion there was no Mass rape
there was no murder historically
historically non-muslim documentation
there is a Muslim there is a movie they
just recently made about Saladin you can
see all that right but now you look at
the opposite the Spanish Inquisition
when the people from France and other
parts when they went and took the more
Spain which the Moors had ruled for
hundreds of years they massacred
Devastation everybody
every Muslim was either killed or forced
to convert every Jew was either killed
or forced to convert every Christian
that didn't follow their form of
Christianity was either the Spanish
Inquisition was a genocide
and a master they didn't leave a single
mosque standing they didn't leave as
best they could not a single Muslim in
Spain look at the hypocrisy there in
Islam we have the akam of halodemma we
protect the rights of non-muslims
when we look at the the Crusaders and
the rape and massacres they did with the
cross read your history before we talk
and that's why we say the divine mercy
of the Quran sets those laws to protect
human rights okay go ahead go ahead
please just in context of these guys who
that Charlie you know they are hoping
they are hoping that Muslims will be
wiped away because of earthquakes
actually this is something that will
never happen
uh there is uh
a narrations
so for the people hearing this for the
first time you're going now deep you're
going into the into the preserved text
yes and you're looking when Allah
revealed the following verse
from the Quran now yes
is the one who is able in reference to
Allah foreign
that you make my ummah perish because of
a punishment that
comes that would be like you know
thunderstorms and all these or
foreign
or from beneath your feet
all the scholars said earthquakes
the prophet saws
I seek refuge in your face that my ummah
would be wiped Away by a collective
earthquake yeah individual earthquakes
yes it will happen that's something
about like the entire community of
Muslims no Charlie Abdul is not going to
happen
here is the interesting piece
or he would turn you into groups
factions the Muslim Community
that you have internal dispute and
conflict
so the prophet said that my ummah will
be divided Allah said to him no this one
no
this is
if they choose then that's their way
before we conclude tell us how to for
the person trying to make sense of this
they're not well grounded maybe Nadine
you know a borderline jumping from here
there and they don't
understand why they could have been
there going through it or outside
they're looking why is this happening to
Muslims why how can they go ahead and
make sense of this
we talked about this in German as well
um
this life is a test and one of the signs
of the day of judgment as the prophet
Allah is an increase in earthquake so
there's a prophecy to this there's a
prophecy to this and we're seeing it
every year we're seeing so it's a
fulfillment of the prophecy so fulfill
so many of these you can find us yes of
course the prophesies coming yes one of
the signs of the day of Judgment of the
Prophet peace and blessings be upon them
in the authentic nourishing told us is
an increase in earthquakes and that's
from it and we've seen that happening
year by year and we're seeing everything
from tsunamis and earthquakes coming and
they're going to hit all parts of the
world and they're going to hit Muslim
parts of the world signs of the day of
judgment signs of the day of judgment
that are coming earthquakes does that
mean that it's it's coming close
actually three of the ten major signs
are earthquakes
you know the minor signs is the increase
but out of the 10 major signs of the day
of judgment there are three earthquakes
one in the East one in the west and one
in the Arabian peninsula
so the increase in earthquakes is
something we should expect and we know
that every Prophecy of the Prophet peace
and blessings upon him has come true and
what hasn't yet will come true so this
is going to happen now we need to
understand that this is a reminder for
the Muslim ummah that that this life
isn't it look people say how could a
child be killed in a natural disaster
how could God allow this understand
something none of us have a guarantee of
how long we're going to live none of us
bought life like as if we're going to
get a return policy or something right
Allah wrote it for us a child that dies
before puberty before hitting the age of
Baloo will be in Jannah and he will be
in Paradise because he never reached an
age where he's going to be questioned
and in Jannah he will be a grown man so
he will have or a boy or a grown woman
for a girl so what does that tell you
that if some child dies maybe a
five-year-old six-year-old we see that
very negatively but in reality it's good
for the child
in this world yet his life didn't get to
be 20 and 30 and 40 but he will live
forever and ever in general this is
yes I was going to get killed yeah yeah
it's a very good point yeah beat me to
it masha'allah if you look at the story
of Musa and if you don't know
if you can write you can read about the
prophet Musa peace and blessing be upon
him with peace and blessings be upon him
doing things that he didn't comprehend
he was unable to
contain himself because he was very
strict on right and wrong and then one
of the things explained him about the
child that he killed and how that young
man was to grow up and be a a means of
misguidance for himself and for his
parents
so Allah chose from his Mercy that he
dies at an age where he will still enter
the paradise now think about the parents
they would only see that their young
child died
they would not know the wisdom behind it
so to them it was a Calamity but in
reality it was the best for them and
their child
so when some hardship happens upon the
Muslim we are patient
we do not question other why it happened
it happened because Allah wrote it you
know and we do not question the wisdom
of it because we know Allah knows better
than us and we know whatever befalls us
is best for us the prophet peace and
blessings be upon him said in the
authentic narration that I am amazed by
the condition of the believer
and this is for none but the believer
the men the believer
that if something good happened he
Praises Allah Allah increases the good
and if he has to some hardship he is
patient and Allah forgives his sins and
elevates his ranks because of his
patient so when we are hit with
calamities we don't question why we say
you know what happened we are patient
and we know that there is an everlasting
life in Jannah that is the real life
so this knife is temporary anyway I mean
little children being born in hospitals
and in the U.S sometimes diet at the
point of being born
whether you die that way or under
earthquake or a fire in the end that is
what life was written for you but if you
may get into that paradise meaning if
you die whether you're even from a
non-muslim household and you die before
the age of Baloo right
or you live past that and you are able
to earn through your good deeds the
mercy of Allah right and then you enter
Jannah either way if you enter in
Paradise you made it you're successful
so this life doesn't really matter it's
just a test so this life voided the
Hereafter doesn't make sense but now as
you narrated in Islam having the
categories of somebody you could start
making sense of it how you pass away how
you die even in this situation can it be
a means for you to achieve Paradise
passed by the prophet saw Allah
so the prophet said
this person's janaza whether he rested
or whether he is being arrested from
so the after the janaza you see the
prophet is respecting the Jannah he
didn't say anything but after the janaza
passed the janaza procession so the
companions asked him
who are those
he said the one who rested is the
believing man and woman
when they die they take a break from
life and they go to Allah his Mercy can
you imagine that this is why Eddie the
prophet saws at one time he made a
statement in front of Allah
he said whoever loves to meet Allah
Allah would love to meet him
the companions know quite well that the
only time you're going to meet Allah is
when we die on the day of judgment or in
Jannah foreign
but the believing slave
when he is going through the agonies of
death
the Angels who came to prepare him for
the angel of death to extract his soul
and this is
requires Muslim
they will tell him you did good with
your life you were successful you
succeeded in your test and you know
Jannah is out there waiting for you and
don't worry about what you're going to
leave behind at that time okay let me go
take my soul I want to die I want to go
to Allah
even when they carry him
they carry him to the cemetery for
barrio look at this now
he's asking the people who are carrying
him drive come on now drive now walk
walk that's why we have this culture
that his janaza was flying you know that
that's a sign that that you know because
he loves to meet Allah you see did
Charlie up do people don't know that
stuff I I understand that they may
assume that we're suicide no we're not
suicidal but we have a different
perspective on death death is a break
but what matters how you diet and
imagine these brothers and sisters those
twenty thousand they have a good chance
of receiving the status of martyrdom
Shahid but again we don't say that we
don't say for sure only Allah knows but
we ask Allah to Grant each one of them
the ruling of Shaheed imagine that what
is the ruling of Jannah
I don't even want to get into it that's
a whole other session but these people
like from Charlie how about this but
just to add the Sheikh mashallah cover
the the points but one more point for
the living
is testing you
whether to expiate a sinio committed or
whether to raise your rank one of the
two
look at this
any
any any Calamity or hardship
anything that inflect the Believers and
that's what the Sheikh mentioned
look at this anything even depression
even a moment of grievance sadness but
Allah will explain yourself
Allah will explain the sin that you
committed so this is cleansing to the
ummah but like the Sheikh mentioned
is
sending this Ayah to make us fear so we
got a fear we gotta come back to Allah
in Repentance this is how we look at
death you know even the death of
children the Sheikh mentioned you know
that it actually could be good it's a
great reminder life can just flip upside
down literally like at any moment it can
all be taken away it can all end so we
have to be prepared for what comes next
after this and physically and mentally
we always have to remember that there is
a greater purpose a greater
I don't even want to get into now it's
another session but for people like
you're saying they need help they need
the guidance if they don't go ahead and
start reading this Quran they don't
start taking the guy they start being at
a persistent
opponents to the truth and mocking and
whatnot and if they die upon this
there's a clear description just like
there's a description for Paradise
there's a clear description of what will
happen to people like that in the
Hellfire isn't there absolutely detailed
yeah yeah yeah yeah so maybe that they
should read that maybe that'll scare
them straight yeah well that's the thing
I mean people need to realize there's
only two destinations only two either
you're going to be in Paradise forever
or you're going to be in a Hellfire
about forever and ever so you can mark
all you want in this life you can you
can make any kind of cartoon you can
burn whatever you can make jokes you can
use your double standards but in the end
you're gonna go back to Allah and you're
gonna stand in front of Allah and you're
going to give your account now there's
no other place to go
so this is why as Muslims we want good
for everybody we don't want to see these
people even from Charlie abdoor these
people burning the Quran or Islam may
Allah guide them I don't want to see
them in the Hellfire
we want them to be in Jannah with us
but the path to Jannah is to believe in
the one Creator is to accept the Quran
the words of Allah to accept the prophet
of the last prophet Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him and
that's what we call everybody towards is
to believe in that one Creator the same
one that Abraham and Moses and Jesus and
Muhammad peace and blessing be upon all
of them believed in and to submit that's
what Muslim is we submit ourselves and I
want to just make this point in the end
we for our brothers and sisters in in
Turkey in Syria and Lebanon and
everywhere that is affected by This
calamity we feel your pain and we are
with you in this and for those that are
out there in those countries and we know
there are non-muslims that live in those
countries that are going through those
hardships we feel your pain as well we
we feel that as a part of the same Human
family that originated from the same
Adam and Eve that we all come from and
we want good for everybody and as
Muslims and as we've been seeing news
reports for the Muslims in turkey and
other places for non-muslims that were
there that got caught up that were that
are helping them just as they're helping
any Muslim in that Calamity we want to
make sure we preserve and protect life
preserve and protect life
anything I'll say before we conclude
that's it you know I enjoyed it that was
beautifully you said thank you very much
thank you very much it's an honor to sit
next to your Kareem and benefit from him
upon he's our uh he's our role model
here inshallah
we were both of you thank you so much
I'd like to spend some time with us and
going over these always a pleasure
talking to you thank you likewise
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedenshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum